from your experience what if you learn
ah let's see the biggest the biggest the
biggest the biggest when you're working
with other people you have to be patient
because at this level of filmmaking
guaranteed you're asking somebody to do
something for nothing so it's be patient
you know and that's the one thing I
learned with a Redemption that taught me
a lot B was because I was asking a lot
of graphics editors and guys to really
help me out with the graphics and
redemption and I learned so much on that
one because the lighting was so bad or
redemption it affected the graphics are
you know creators and because lighting
lighting is everything so if you're
going to do graphics you better make
sure your graphics guy is on the set
with you so he can make sure the
lightning is what he needs to do his job
in post-production so because I didn't
have the lighting setup properly for
that and I had issues with overexposure
and things I went through several
graphics you know editors working on my
project and you know only then we're
pretty much working for nothing even
when I paid them it's listen these guys
get paid well for doing what they're
doing so what I'm offering is nothing so
if they do it for me they're usually
doing it because they're passionate for
the problem for the project and then
they're really into it you know
themselves and they put a lot of time
into it so I said that's the number one
thing is uh be patient fish you know
wait and let people do it on their time
they're not going to do it as fast as
you want to do it because you know
finish your project exactly it's your
baby so you know be nice be patient and
be grateful no matter what they do
as well as an act was but like i said i
never took acting classes period you
know i mean so my first acting lesson
was actually on the weight dumping first
time actually acted in short so I
learned I learned all about characters
and character choices just on that
project alone you know again like you
said I have to be patient and I had to
listen our old Keesey listening
listening and reacting to what the other
person is saying so I kind of learned
all of that from that short long and
from now on you can see from the second
film Redemption a sudden gain more and
more comfortable from the camera until
amber and amber I was just taking breaks
and hanging out and because I surveyed I
really feel at ease and comfortable
about that time but it was all the
growing and learning experience from
that the person to the film do we do now
you